Những bắt với chào tạm gẹt dừa bảo gia gì, dự báo năm tất bảo nữ đuôi nhau đến cuối năm.
Theo tông tin trên bảo hửa đưa tin, nhận định về suy tế thời kết xa hơn, ông Mai Van Khiem
sẵn đốc chung tâm dự báo khi tự thị bán có trà, tổng cục khi tự bán cho hay, tự tháng mời đến tháng mẹ hai
nè mài nàn công trăm hai mẹ tư, có khoảng bủy tế năm cơn bảo át thấp nhật lời trên cú vực đến đồng.
Đáng chú ý, thất tính của vực liên chung cần ra sốt thấp nán sẵn sản ứng phóng ngồi lũ, cực ra trong tháng mời tháng mời một hai không hai mẹ tư.
Bên cạnh đó, người dân cơ lư ý đến lũ đam hai nàn công trăm hai mẹ tư, ở cất sông từ khoảng bình đến khánh hoa ở mức báo đậm hai báo đậm ba,
và trên báo đậm ba, thất sông ở vũ yên, ninh thật, lình thật, trên báo đậm hai.
Lũ năm hai nàn công trăm hai mẹ tư, ở đồng 1 xong cú lâm sau đậu ở trên mức báo đậm một,
đình lũ tại các trạng hà lũ sông của lâm ở mức báo đậm hai báo đậm ba và trên báo đậm ba.
Pởi đình lũ dữ báo như vậy, khả nâng cao nhất trong khoảng bũ năm gần đây và thất hơn năm hai nàn công trăm mời tâm, ông khiến cho hai.